I was just looking on the
discussion boards on the Khan
Academy Facebook page, and Bud
Denny put up this problem,
asking for it to be solved.
And it seems like a problem
of general interest.
If the indefinite integral of
2 to the natural log of x
over, everything over x, dx.
And on the message board, Abhi
Khanna also put up a solution,
and it is the correct solution,
but I thought this was of
general interest, so I'll
make a quick video on it.
So the first thing when you see
an integral like this, is you
say, hey, you know, I have this
natural log of x up in
the numerator, and
where do I start?
And the first thing that should
maybe pop out at you, is that
this is the same thing as the
integral of one over x times 2
to the natural log of x, dx.
And so you have an expression
here, or it's kind of part of
our larger function, and you
have its derivative, right?
We know that the derivative,
let me write it over here, we
know that the derivative with
respect to x of the natural
log of x is equal to 1/x.
So we have some expression, and
we have its derivative, which
tells us that we can
use substitution.
Sometimes you can do in your
head, but this problem, it's
still not trivial to
do in your head.
So let's make the substitution.
Let's substitute this
right here with a u.
So let's do that.
So if you define u, and it
doesn't have to be u, it's
just, that's the convention,
it's called u-substitution, it
could have been s-substitution
for all we care.
Let's say u is equal to the
natural log of x, and then du
dx, the derivative of u with
respect to x, of course
is equal to 1/x.
Or, just the differential du,
if we just multiply both sides
by dx is equal to 1 over x dx.
So let's make our substitution.
This is our integral.
So this will be equal to the
indefinite integral, or the
antiderivative, of 2 to the
now u, so 2 to the u,
times 1 over x dx.
Now what is 1 over x dx?
That's just du.
So this term times that
term is just our du.
Let me do it in a
different color.
1 over x times dx is
just equal to du.
That's just equal to that
thing, right there.
Now, this still doesn't look
like an easy integral, although
it's gotten simplified
a good bit.
And to solve, you know,
whenever I see the variable
that I'm integrating against
in the exponent, you know,
we don't have any easy
exponent rules here.
The only thing that I'm
familiar with, where I have my
x or my variable that I'm
integrating against in
my exponent, is the
case of e to the x.
We know that the integral of
e to the x, dx, is equal
to e to the x plus c.
So if I could somehow turn this
into some variation of e to the
x, maybe, or e to the u, maybe
I can make this integral a
little bit more tractable.
So let's see.
How can we redefine
this right here?
Well, 2, 2 is equal to what?
2 is the same thing as e to
the natural log of 2, right?
The natural log of 2 is
the power you have to
raise e to to get 2.
So if you raise e to
that power, you're, of
course going to get 2.
This is actually the definition
of really, the natural log.
You raise e to the natural log
of 2, you're going to get 2.
So let's rewrite this, using
this-- I guess we could call
this this rewrite or-- I
don't want to call it
quite a substitution.
It's just a different way
of writing the number 2.
So this will be equal to,
instead of writing the number
2, I could write e to
the natural log of 2.
And all of that to the u du.
And now what is this equal to?
Well, if I take something to an
exponent, and then to another
exponent, this is the same
thing as taking my base to the
product of those exponents.
So this is equal to, let me
switch colors, this is equal
to the integral of e,
to the u, e to the, let
me write it this way.
e to the natural
log of 2 times u.
I'm just multiplying
these two exponents.
I raise something to something,
then raise it again, we know
from our exponent rules,
it's just a product of
those two exponents.
du.
Now, this is just a constant
factor, right here.
This could be, you know, this
could just be some number.
We could use a calculator to
figure out what this is.
We could set this equal to a.
But we know in general that
the integral, this is pretty
straightforward, we've
now put it in this form.
The antiderivative of e
to the au, du, is just
1 over a e to the au.
This comes from this definition
up here, and of course plus
c, and the chain rule.
If we take the derivative of
this, we take the derivative
of the inside, which
is just going to be a.
We multiply that times the
one over a, it cancels
out, and we're just
left with e to the au.
So this definitely works out.
So the antiderivative of this
thing right here is going to be
equal to 1 over our a, it's
going to be 1 over our constant
term, 1 over the natural log of
2 times our whole
expression, e e.
And I'm going to do something.
This is just some number times
u, so I can write it as
u times some number.
And I'm just doing that to put
in a form that might help us
simplify it a little bit.
So it's e to the u times the
natural log of 2, right?
All I did, is I
swapped this order.
I could have written this
as e to the natural
log of 2 times u.
If this an a, a times u is
the same thing as u times a.
Plus c.
So this is our answer, but we
have to kind of reverse
substitute before we can feel
satisfied that we've taken
the antiderivative
with respect to x.
But before I do that, let's
see if I can simplify
this a little bit.
What is, if I have, just from
our natural log properties,
or logarithms, a times
the natural log of b.
We know this is the same
thing as the natural
log of b to the a.
Let me draw a line here.
Right?
That this becomes the exponent
on whatever we're taking
the natural log of.
So u, let me write this here,
u times the natural log of
2, is the same thing as the
natural log of 2 to the u.
So we can rewrite our
antiderivative as being equal
to 1 over the natural log of 2,
that's just that part here,
times e to the, this can be
rewritten based on this
logarithm property, as the
natural log of 2 to the u, and
of course we still have
our plus c there.
Now, what is e raised to the
natural log of 2 to the u?
The natural log of 2 to the u
is the power that you have to
raise e to to get to
2 to the u, right?
By definition!
So if we raise e to that power,
what are we going to get?
We're going to get 2 to the u.
So this is going to be equal to
1 over the natural log of 2.
This simplifies to
just 2 to the u.
I drew it up here.
The natural log a I could just
write in general terms, let
me do it up here, and maybe
I'm beating a dead horse.
But I can in general write any
number a as being equal to
e to the natural log of a.
This is the exponent you have
to raise e to to get a.
If you raise e to that,
you're going to get a.
So e to the natural log of 2 to
the u, that's just 2 to the u.
And then I have my
plus c, of course.
And now we can
reverse substitute.
What did we set u equal to?
We defined u, up here, as equal
to the natural log of x.
So let's just reverse
substitute right here.
And so the answer to our
original equation, your answer
to, let me write it here,
because it's satisfying when
you see it, to this kind of
fairly convoluted-looking
antiderivative problem, 2 to
the natural log of x over x dx,
we now find is equal to, we
just replaced u with natural
log of x, because that was our
substitution, and 1 over the
natural log of 2 times 2 to the
natural log of x plus c.
And we're done.
This isn't in the denominator,
the way I wrote it might
look a little ambiguous.
And we're done!
And that was a pretty neat
problem, and so thanks
to Bud for posting that.